hello friends I'm Ilana and welcome to
my channel where today I wanted to make
another quick news update video
basically because people are freaking
out about something that I don't think
they should be freaking out about in
case you missed the news today it was
announced that cyberpunk 2077 is not
going to have gender options for
characters basically sub sexes of the
internet as I saying confused I'm using
Joe's tweet as an example not because I
have any problem which are just because
I responded to him so it makes sense to
do that
he said I'm confused so it's been
confirmed there's no longer binary
gender options in cyberpunk 2077 as they
removed them so what if I want to select
male though there are a few angry
replies and here's people being like you
can present as male but you won't be
male and I'm not buying this game I was
looking forward to it too but I'm not
supporting this brute stupidity anymore
most of the people there pandering to
weren't even going to buy the game in
the first place as a guy he is saying
absolute [ __ ] lost a lot of
respect to CDP after learning about this
crap it seems a social justice cancer is
sadly spread to them as well now it's
only a matter of time before it spreads
the whole video games industry these are
sad days indeed and I think a lot of
this got traction specifically because
of the quartering who is a youtuber who
in his video was a lot more well
reasoned than this tweet makes him sound
way he said breaking news cyberpunk
removes Genda you cannot be a male a
female so that 0 so that certain point 0
5 percent people don't get offended
super sad to see Projekt RED his red
panda at this level of what if I won't
identify as a male now I feel like
scooter from scam watchin [ __ ] but I
don't believe that
CD Projekt RED did this in any way that
relates to social justice or politics at
all even though that wouldn't make sense
in the cyberpunk universe but I don't
think that's what happened to you so
this came out because of an interview
with Metro I'm just taking it from IGN
here Jean cos who is a senior concept
artist said a character creation menu
for instance compared to the last demo
we now give you so many more options for
instance you don't choose your gender
anymore you don't choose I want to be a
male or female character you now choose
body type because we want you to feel
free to create any character you want
and it basically yeah it goes on to say
the developers opting out of strict
binary for things like gender instead
you choose a body type and to voice
options one that's male sounding one
that's female sounding you can mix and
match you can just connect them
anyway you want but as I responded to
Joe who said what if I want to select
male vote basically what it would mean
is that you select a male voice in a
male body type and that's your character
this also has happened in games before
I've just pulled up a video of the same
34 character created here for anyone who
doesn't remember it basically you had
the options to pick body face hair
makeup personality whatever that's what
you start with in the character crater
and then you choose body sex so he's
chosen a male sex as the body and you
could choose whatever voice you wanted
it's basically the exact same thing
sunset overdrive did this as well I
believe and for games like those which
are goofy and fun I think it makes the
most sense for them that you get to
express yourself however the hell you
want to in a goofy creative over-the-top
world where you know the goddamn
president and their aliens and it's
insane in cyberpunk where things are a
lot more serious it makes more sense
from a lore perspective and for people
who are like well what are they gonna
call thee this is a screenshot posted by
AC wonder up on Twitter which looks like
it's from reddit originally where
someone deemed cyberpunk or CD Projekt
RED and said hey I heard rumors you got
rid of gendered speech / he / chief of E
is that true because I want to play as
male and be addressed like one and they
responded regarding gendered speech
specifically and said no worries that
will be possible just to like double
check I kind of ran on the assumption
before even playing the game that you
would be called V in the same way that
you called Shepherd shepherd in Mass
Effect so I don't feel like that was a
big deal but I guess it sounds like you
will still be called he or she even
though nobody really says that to your
face they call you you or your own name
but I guess this will apply and be an
option for when you hear people talking
about to you but one of the big points
is that the body is just supposed to be
a vessel for your brain you should be
able to change limbs at any point that
you want to in a cyber point future it
doesn't matter if you cut your arm off
and replace it with a gun if you want to
have a feminine sounding voice and a
masculine body I don't think anyone
would care because that is absolutely
part of the law part of the world people
are swapping their eyes out people are
throwing limbs away
like it's candy if you want to put a
dick on top of your existing dick I
don't think anyone would mind you doing
that in cyberpunk 2077 basically for the
people who are like well what if I want
to just play as a dude you still get to
play as a man the point is just that the
stuff that makes you a man is very very
arbitrary in this universe you can do
whatever you want be whoever you want
buy whatever upgrade you want to your
body because your body is just the sack
of meat that holds your brain in place
not even a really be that extent because
part of its that your brain doesn't
matter you can just have a chip up there
if you want to you can get rid of your
body entirely and be a ghost in a system
like Keanu Reeves character is going to
be so I think anyone getting caught up
in the fact that you can't choose to be
a man or a woman in a cyberpunk universe
doesn't really make any sense you can
just present however you want as a mega
Chie here put it in response to my
conversation with Jo a big aspect of
cyberpunk is all about transhumanism the
removal of minor agendas falls right in
line
it is about inclusiveness it's about
respecting the source material subject
in era this is a huge plus for emotion
and authenticity and while they do
mention that part of it is about
inclusion I think that for the most part
this is true I don't feel like they
implemented these changes just to make
it so that trans people feel more
comfortable playing so I would 120 77 I
feel like it just makes more sense for
their character creator based on the
world that you live in so I guess my
point is this this doesn't really change
anything no it actually doesn't change
anything full stuff is not going to
change how you play the game at all
other games have done it before and it
didn't affect those games and it also
just very much fits with the cyberpunk
universe so for people who are like well
it's confusing I don't know what it
means I just what if I just want to play
as a man you still can you just choose
male body male voice and it's the same
thing but again you're gonna be
modifying the hell out of yourself
inside of punk 2077 I have seen footage
of this game a couple of times and sorry
I got distracted looking at a nipple
skip ahead just skipping ahead or I'm
gonna keep staring at that there we go
get a Jackie but basically the point is
just as you play through cyberpunk 2077
your male or female body isn't really
gonna matter by the end because
based on what we've seen and what
they've told us you can be customizing
the hell out of yourself like this guy
with his fake gold arm
chip in the side of his head like I
don't think we need to be too worried
about gender and sex in a future where
you can do whatever the hell you want
with your body and that's part of the
appeal of it so yeah ultimately you want
to make this video to be like you people
are reading a little bit too much into
this everybody needs to chill out it is
not a big deal this is not part of a
liberal cultural war it's just a really
minor point of a character creator that
that is doing something very similar to
what other games have done and very much
fits in with the universe and that's
pretty much it it's probably a really
quick video I just felt like I should
make it I'll probably keep making these
instead of like putting a rant on
Twitter this is basically me making a
video like this instead just like a
clearing things up for you friends also
yes if you notice behind me I'm not
using my green screen today my PC is
sort of in my kitchen I mean a studio
apartment it's not technically but my
kitchen is sort of behind me the PCs not
really in it but that is a stove it's
further away than it looks I swear that
is my fridge this webcam doesn't have
great depth of field already everyone
I'm Alana and I will see you guys next
time